courtney cox's new man could I be any
more turned on the Friends star and
rocker Johnny McDaid just called off
their engagement earlier this month and
now she seems to be moving on et cam
reports the actress went on a dinner
date with actor Will Arnett Tuesday
night and our source says they were
quote all over each other the pair hit
up the palm restaurant in Beverly Hills
and our source tells us they attempted
to quote sneak out after with the
manager helping them leave it separately
forty-five-year-old our net is Amy
Poehler's ex-husband he and 51 year old
[ __ ] do have plenty in common they've
both starred in scripted comedies and
they have mutual friends jennifer
aniston and justin theroux the road told
ET earlier this year but will is part of
his close group of pals but notably a
source close to Cox tells ET she and
Arnett are just pals so what do you
think would you like to see you will in
courtenay dating let us know on twitter
using the hashtag ET now
you